[Musica]
madonna
si
[Musica]
guarda
questo che avete appena visto è un video
realizzato da me circa due anni fa e che
immortala un evento che ha rappresentato
uno dei momenti più emozionanti della
mia vita e credo l'abbiate percepito
nella mia voce e in quella dei miei
bambini è il lancio di solar orbiter
da che canaveral in florida nel febbraio
solar orbiter è un satellite con a bordo
dieci strumenti scientifici
che sta già osservando il sole dal punto
più vicino mai raggiunto da una sonda
con telescopi a bordo che è più o meno a
circa un terzo della distanza terra sole
il lancio di solar orbiter mi è così
caro non perché ho potuto viaggiare per
tutta la florida
oddio anche ma perché io lavoro come
ricercatrice dell'istituto nazionale di
astrofisica
all'osservatorio astronomico di
capodimonte e in particolare mi occupo
proprio di sole
stasera quindi vorrei condurvi con me in
questo viaggio per farvelo osservare da
un punto di vista diverso che è quello
di una il mio che è quello di
un'astrofisica solare perché
perché così importante studiare il sole
è perché ci interessa capirne il
comportamento
in fondo abbiamo sempre vissuto e anche
bene dando per scontate sia la sua
presenza sia la sua incessabile
fornitura di energia alla terra che ha
permesso alla vita di svilupparsi così
come la conosciamo e senza la quale
sappiamo che cesti guerin bo in
pochissimo tempo quindi una volta
rassicurati sul fatto che il sole
terminerà la sua vita tra almeno 4
miliardi di anni e che quindi il suo
spegnimento non è un fenomeno che ci
riguarderà fortunatamente allora perché
dovremmo interessarci al suo studio
immaginate di essere nel vostro ufficio
alla vostra scrivania con il vostro
computer collegato alla rete elettrica e
che a un certo punto quest'ultimo si
spenga vi alzate andate a controllare il
funzionamento di altri dispositivi
elettronici nelle vicinanze ma è tutto
spento
prendete il cellulare per segnalare il
guasto ma nemmeno il cellulare funziona
ne avete linea dati anche il gps non va
quindi siete senza internet senza social
praticamente in una tragedia
fantascienza
no questi eventi si sono già verificati
ad esempio nel 2003 in svezia o nel 1989
in quebec dove
senza di energia elettrica
durò per diverse ore fin quando non si
riuscì ad individuare il danno è a
ripararlo
quindi da questo risulta chiaro visto
che il responsabile fu proprio il sole
soprattutto adesso che basiamo la nostra
vita quasi completamente sulla
tecnologia e lo faremo sempre di più in
futuro che è necessario capire cosa
avviene durante questi eventi e magari
cercare anche di prevederli proprio
attraverso lo studio del comportamento
del sole infatti pensare di rimanere
senza energia elettrica per più di un
ora e impossibile e comporterebbe gravi
danni a tutta la tecnologia
compresa quella relativa a
operazioni salvavita come quelle
sanitarie quelle militari o quelle
legate alle telecomunicazioni
cosa avviene durante questi eventi
dal sole proviene costantemente un
flusso di particelle cariche detto vento
solare che sfugge all'attrazione
gravitazionale e arriva fino ai confini
del sistema solare e quindi giunge anche
alla terra
in questa immagine sulla sinistra vedete
il sole mentre sulla destra quel piccolo
pallino blu e la nostra terra siamo noi
circondata dalla sua magnetosfera che
originata dal campo magnetico terrestre
e che ci scherma generalmente da questo
flusso di particelle cariche
il sole però può produrre oltre al vento
solare anche delle tempeste solari
che consistono in una nuvola
improvvisa che viene espulsa dal sole
con velocità altissime di particelle
cariche e campo magnetico che riesce a
sorpassare la barriera protettiva del
campo magnetico arriva fino agli strati
più alti della nostra atmosfera e in
alcuni casi può provocare gravi danni ai
satelliti delle telecomunicazioni ai
satelliti di posizione quindi gps ma
anche alle centrali elettriche e alle
linee dell'alta tensione a terra
quindi
queste tempeste possono essere molto
pericolose anche per la vita nello
spazio ad esempio per gli astronauti a
bordo della stazione spaziale
internazionale o in previsione di futuri
viaggi su altri pianeti si manifestano
particolarmente maggiormente quando
siamo vicini ad un massimo dell'attività
solare e lo stiamo proprio raggiungendo
in questi anni quindi saranno un periodo
in cui saremo maggiormente esposti però
questo è anche il periodo maggiore visto
che si verifica ogni 11 anni è il
periodo più adatto per studiare questi
fenomeni
fenomeni che comunque hanno il loro
fascino
infatti nei casi più fortunati
senza l'attività solare non potremmo
godere della bellezza delle aurore
polari che sono proprio il risultato
dell'interazione delle particelle
cariche che provengono dal sole con
l'atmosfera e il campo magnetico della
terra
qual è il mio ruolo io in particolare mi
occupo di studiare il campo magnetico
solare che è il principale responsabile
di questi eventi e le sue interazioni
con la materia di cui è composto il sole
in particolare studio i fenomeni
eruttivi
capire quando in che condizioni si possa
verificare appunto un espulsione di
materia che può colpire la terra questa
è una mia osservazione di un filamento
solare che sta eruttando
ottenuta a tenerife quindi con un
telescopio da terra ma utilizzo anche
dati da satellite ad esempio come questi
che stiamo vedendo adesso che sono
proprio di solar orbiter
e l'idea è quella di mettere insieme
informazioni da più strumenti proprio
per seguire una particella che viene
espulsa dal sole e arriva fino a terra
in genere le tempeste solari impiegano
da uno a tre giorni per giungere a terra
ma importante conoscerne l'arrivo con
precisione spaziale e temporale
questi eventi sono sempre esistiti però
non ne vedevamo gli effetti a terra
proprio perché non avevamo la tecnologia
che abbiamo adesso
quindi questa rete di satelliti ed i
telescopi che monitorano costantemente
il sole ci permette di una volta
[Musica]
vista insomma una tempesta solare che
sta arrivando a terra di definire e
programmare dei black out in modo tale
da proteggere i satelliti le centrali
elettriche in funzione da questo flusso
di particelle
quindi il lo studio del sole ha un
impatto sulla nostra quotidianità ma
questa non è una novità se ci sono
numerosi esempi di
invenzioni
adottate per permetterci di
esplorare l'universo o scoperte fatte
con il naso all'insù che una volta
implementate nello spazio sono state
implementate anche sulla terra e hanno
letteralmente salvato vite umane
penso alle coperte termiche che derivano
da gli scudi termici
che proteggono i satelliti che si
avvicinano il sole oppure alle
mammografie o ancora alla possibilità di
avere acqua potabile in zone della terra
dove acqua non ce n'è
in realtà questa azione di guardare
all'esterno e quindi mettere una
distanza tra noi e i nostri problemi è
un consiglio il suggerimento che si dà o
si riceve quando siamo impelagati in
difficoltà interne in problemi interni e
non riusciamo a risolverli quindi il mio
invito è quello di tornare a guardare il
sole mi raccomando sempre con appositi
filtri e mai ad occhio nudo perché è
pericolosissimo quindi di tornare a
guardare il sole non solo come fonte di
vita ma anche come parte inter agente
del sistema in cui viviamo e con cui
dobbiamo convivere e anche come
soluzione a problemi terrestri che
quindi ci permette di risolvere
determinati problemi e di conseguenza ci
permette di evolvere
grazie
[Applauso]